I'm Greg Jarrett I'm Sandra Smith I'm
Charles Payne and this is the Fox News
Rundown
Friday April 7th 2020 23. I'm Jared
Halpern the former president's arrest
and arraignment is dominating the
political landscape so how does a
president or a presidential candidate
rise above it there is a huge swath of
the country and if the Republican Party
certainly that likes that Trump is a
fighter this puts him in fighter mode we
speak with Fox News Sunday host Shannon
bream I'm Dave Anthony we've already let
you hear some of Benjamin Hall's
harrowing Tale
surviving a Russian attack all he
reported on the war in Ukraine
today you hear the rest everything that
I fought for was getting home every
single day no matter how hard it was
that's what I held in my mind keep going
you're going home you'll see your family
again you'll hold your daughters again
and I'm Robert Jeffress I've got the
final word on the Fox News Rundown
[Music]
President Biden doesn't have anything to
say about his predecessors day in court
neither does his press secretary Kareem
Jean-Pierre what's important to the
president is to continue to focus on the
American people that is what's important
to the president so he's good to lay low
for a couple news Cycles so look here's
the thing here's the thing Peter and
this is what we will speak to we will
speak to the fact that that this is a
president that has been able to
get historic pieces of legislation done
President Biden and members of his
administration like the vice president
and cabinet officials are spending the
next few weeks on the road going to
factories and Tech hubs highlighting
American manufacturing breaking through
this week after the historic arrest and
arraignment of former president Trump
isn't just a challenge for the White
House though Congressional Republicans
and Republicans running for president
are also spending time reacting to the
case defending Trump and announcing what
they see is a political prosecution
instead of say getting as much ink as
they like about new energy legislation
and it's been a boost so far for former
president Trump remember what president
Trump said weeks ago at CPAC that if he
got indicted he definitely would not get
out of the race and he thought it would
help his numbers Shannon bream is the
anchor of Fox News Sunday and the author
of the new bestseller the love stories
of the Bible speak biblical lessons on
romance friendship and faith I mean he
was very prescient about that and it's
forced all of his current rivals or
potential Rivals to fall in line and
defend him and talk about this
prosecution's overzealous and it's
political and he's our guy kind of I
mean it really in the primary scenario
was working out the best it possibly
could for him I mean in this in the face
of getting indicted nobody wants that I
don't think but to his political
Advantage I mean it's paying dividends
well let's talk about sort of the steps
with that and I'm so glad that I can
lean on your legal expertise here for a
little bit because I was surprised at
least initially when I saw that the
judge said all right our next hearing is
going to be December 4th and I thought
December 4th my goodness that's a long
time right um and then some other
attorneys that were talking were saying
well actually it's really not that's
pretty standard in a white collar sort
of case like this what is going to
happen between now and then and are we
going to learn anything new between now
and then I mean I think it's possible we
should get more detailed information
from
um what Bragg has put together because
the indictment doesn't State the
underlying crime explicitly so I think
we're going to get more that information
it's going to be a lot of pre-trial
motions back and forth I think that you
know people across the Spectrum left
right and Center do think that this is
probably a legally weak case and that
that it could be very susceptible to
motions to dismiss in other pre-trial
motions to kind of get rid of this thing
so I think you're going to see a lot of
that we should tell people there's a lot
of hurry up and wait in the meantime you
and I are keeping our eyes out for the
Georgia case for the two Federal probes
as well so there will be things
happening in various waves well and that
was the next line that I was going to
sort of go down right because there are
grand jury investigations in Georgia at
the state level and in here in
Washington the special counsel at the
justice department is looking at two
separate lines of inquiry that could
lead to potential indictments or
anything else as it relates to trying to
overturn the election in the documents
uh being mishandled in Mar-A-Lago if
either of those situations leads to an
indictment is there sort of like do you
have to like get in line in other words
um Can those move forward yeah which
would be kind of a campaign nightmare
for the former president because I mean
those things all have to happen they
have to proceed on their own timelines
and they likely will I mean Georgia if
it decides to indict I would guess would
be sooner than the doj only because we
know that grand jury has wrapped up what
they're doing but it looks like the
special Council probes at the doj level
are actually proceeding as well I mean
there's a lot going on there with
Witnesses being called and testimony
being ordered by judges and so I mean
all of these could fall in the former
president's lab by 2024 in the midst of
caucuses and debates and all of those
things it could be a really busy time
for him it's not just the legal trouble
which you know I think is a very real
thing but how do you campaign against
that I mean he will use it as he is
success really done to say look the Deep
State and the establishments after me
but you have to think about the
logistics of being pulled in multiple
different courtrooms and places when
you're supposed to be out you know
eating corn dogs in Iowa so they're the
logistical things too and at some point
you would expect and we've heard it a
little bit I talked to ASA Hutchinson
earlier this week and he sort of said
listen there's just too much chaos
surrounding the former president at some
point you know that's going to have to
be a question for Republican voters
right and it'll be interesting to see if
ASA Hutchinson or Nikki Haley or you
know Rhonda Sanchez or anybody else can
convince Pompeo anybody who may be
getting into the right because they're
going to be a different Lane they're
going to be on the anti-chaos I can get
things done I'm a Statesman but there's
a huge swath of the country and of the
Republican Party certainly that likes
that Trump is a fighter this puts him in
fighter mode and I think that just
reminds them of what they did like about
them about the things that he's willing
to go to the wall and he'll say they're
coming after me to try to get to you
it's a very effective line when you're
trying to excite primary voters so I
don't know that there's a lane for the
anti-chaos candidate and certainly not
more than one right the other thing that
has happened here is we have seen
Republicans really rally around the
former president in so much so is now
we're hearing that they want to subpoena
Alvin Bragg the district attorney what
role would a federal Congressional
inquiry have on a local process
execution I think what part of their you
know argument is going to be that
federal funds do flow to these State
prosecutors or to their offices or into
the state coffers and so that they have
some sort of oversight role for how
federal dollars are spent there's been a
very full-throat of Defense by Bragg's
office saying we run independent
autonomous investigations at the state
level at the local level you have no
right to come and see what we're up to
or call us to Capitol Hill and there are
a lot of folks even you know I would say
center right who say like I don't know
that these committees are really you
know the jurisdiction to do any of this
it would be very interesting to see if
Congress would subpoena him I think he's
probably going to have some pretty
strong legal arguments that he doesn't
need to show up and you know a lot of
people who don't show up for
Congressional subpoenas a handful of
them have paid for it but a lot of them
just kind of skate on with their lives
it'll be interesting to see the other
thing that I think is going to be
interesting because you've heard this as
well maybe Local District Attorneys can
now you know indict Democrats is that
sort of a precedent that's been set or
are there still some sort of legal
guidelines here that are going to set
the rules for the road
well you know you've got house oversight
chair James Comer saying I've gotten
calls from Tennessee from Kentucky from
County Prosecutors there who say they've
got things they want to dig into with
the bidens and already on the hill there
are multiple investigations going on
with various members of the Biden family
and business interests and things that
have gone on there but yeah I mean we
have crossed a line now where um we've
got a prosecution an indictment of a
former president for the first time and
you know I think some of these
prosecutors why would they sit back and
not take advantage of that if this is
going to turn into a political Fiasco
it's sort of like when the left now says
we're going to add seats to the Supreme
Court in the right side great so when we
get in we're going to do it too
um you and I both know covering the hill
that you you try to caution people
whatever party's in charge when they
decide to bust up norms and change rules
to get their things done you got to
remember that the other side is going to
do it when they're in power
mentioned the Supreme Court let's look
at a state supreme court a big win for
the Democrat that flips control of
Wisconsin's Supreme Court on a race that
at least from you know my outside view
seemed to hinge a lot on abortion rights
of access to abortion and long-standing
abortion laws yeah and it wasn't even
close I mean this is one of those things
where Democrats are having some good
nights progressives are having some good
nights yeah Chicago the progressive
mayor ones you know yeah I mean how much
is that a canary in the coal mine for
Republicans like they're really
struggling with this abortion issue do
you embrace it and go full-throated and
say like hey do we want to be like North
Korea or do we want to have more
reasonable restrictions so they've got a
lot of internal strife over this I mean
that Wisconsin race was almost totally
at least in the campaigning and the
discussion about abortion so Republicans
have got to figure out how they're going
to handle that issue because I don't
think they handled it well in the
midterms either and they would have to
admit that and listen we talk about you
know Wisconsin
Michigan these are states that have now
shown that they are going to be maybe
the most important states on the
electoral map in 2024. yeah and they're
the heart of the country they're heart
of that sort of path to the presidential
you know address here in Washington we
think of the heart of the country key
States like Ohio and like you said
Michigan Wisconsin others that you know
are really critical to whoever is going
to take the White House and when you see
so much of the trending blue in these
special elections and different cases
it's got to give the Republicans pause
and I think it points out a couple of
really tough issues that they've got to
deal with
um they used to be that Republicans were
and conservatives were better at turning
out these special elections and getting
mobilized but the left has certainly
figured it out yeah and we've heard that
as well from um you know the RNC
chairman talking about the amount of
money that was spent the Democrat in
that Supreme Court race raised a ton
more money spent a lot more money than
the Republican as well and that's a big
part of winning elections these days
yeah you know a lot of people hate that
kind of leaves a taste in their mouth
but it's true it's sort of like negative
ads like people say like oh it's
terrible I hate them they work get money
out of politics well it works so I until
you find a way to
um I don't know whether you want to
regulate or limit those things
um you got to admit whichever side
you're on they work they do which is why
they keep doing them and keep raising
more money and seeing these tactics play
out let me really quickly there when and
if uh President Biden formally announces
a second term what are you hearing about
that I know that there's kind of this
thought that well you know there's no
rush here right but at some point you do
have to start campaigning
yeah you do but remember this is a
president who won by not doing a lot of
traditional campaigning we were in the
middle of covid he did a lot from his
basement so they probably feel like they
have time I mean the power of the
incumbency is very strong
um you know when I was over at that
lunch the day of the State of the Union
when they fight over journalists to have
lunch with the president that was the
first time that I came away from it
thinking that legitimately there was
some chance he wasn't going to run just
the vibe and the conversation with him
that day I thought I don't think he's
decided 100 that he's actually gonna do
this so it's interesting I mean his
approval ratings are not good he's
upside down on everything from the
border to foreign policy to inflation I
mean there are good numbers but he is
the incumbent and if it's a rematch with
somebody who's beat before he's got to
feel pretty good about those chances
right yeah I've heard that as well too
that you know if Donald Trump is a
republican nominee the scoreboard right
I beat him before yeah that's going to
be his number one argument for sure uh
what are we going to see Sunday on Fox
News Sunday well we've locked in Senator
Lindsey Graham we're going to talk about
a lot of foreign policy
um you know this new unrest in Israel uh
obviously China Taiwan Russia Ukraine
Syria I mean there are so many hot spots
out there we're going to talk about the
rise of AI are we under or overreacting
on that by the way as you well know we
have not settled our debt ceiling or the
budget fight so plenty to talk about we
will be able to probably announce our
Democrat a little bit later today
um but I think we got a lot for our
panel to discuss and we will also have a
special feature on the show that talks
about you know two holy days holy Times
Holy celebrations of Passover and Easter
overlapping each other this year and
kind of what we can learn from each
other's face and on that point
congratulations as well on now the
number two uh bestseller in the New York
Times list the love stories of the Bible
speak thank you so much and thanks to
everyone out there who picked up a copy
and I just hope it'll be encouraging
Shannon always love our chats thanks so
much thank you Jared
[Music]
this is Robert Jeffress with your Fox
News commentary coming up
it's a story so compelling
we had to tell it twice out of nowhere
this big whistle
landed about 30 feet in front of us and
immediately we knew that we were under
attack then Benjamin Hall says a second
bomb hit while he was reporting on the
front lines of the war in Ukraine and it
knocked him out
and then
one of his children
came to him as Eli wounded in a vision
and I saw her right in front of me my
daughter who's called Anna
and she she said Daddy you've got to get
out of the car she said you've got to
get out of the car
and amazingly I I came back I opened my
eyes then the third Russian bomb hit
that one threw me away and the next
thing I know I wake up I'm on fire
my right leg's missing my left foot's
gone I'm bleeding badly he was lying
next to hers Fox News colleague
photographer Pierre zakshevski who did
not survive killed with the rest of the
crew then Ben saw a car go by but they
could not see him lying there I began
dragging myself up the slope towards the
road where that car had passed
and kind of maybe 10 minutes later that
car with Ukrainian Special Forces had
actually got lost down the road and they
came back and at that point I was higher
up and I had a handful of dirt and rocks
and I was throwing it at the car and
they saw me and they in a group called
save our allies helped get our badly
injured reporter on a train to Poland
doesn't matter how you feel right now
you're alive you're going home you've
got to keep going and that's where we
left off in part one
here's the rest of the story of Fox News
correspondent Benjamin Hall who has a
new book saved a war reporter's mission
to make it home I found a new level to
myself on that train when I found a
place where you you have to go when you
when you are experiencing just the worst
and the worst pain you can imagine and
we did it and we got through to Poland
about 10 hours later and on the other
side of the Border there was the
American yeah 82nd Airborne was waiting
for me the Black Hawk was there its
rotors were on and they loaded me onto
that and I was into the hands of the the
US Military and Secretary of Defense
Austin had given me permission special
permission as a journalist to be treated
inside military medicine and that also
saved me I went first to launch stool in
Germany a big US base where all the
injured from Afghanistan and Iraq were
treated they'd seen injuries just like
mine it's called poly trauma you know
limb loss I lost you know a big Burns
traumatic brain injury and they had him
for 10 days before passing me to San
Antonio MC the brook Army Medical Center
and I spent the next six months on a
military base learning how to walk again
learning how to live again and um
fighting to get home again today I speak
to you from home a year later
when did you finally get a chance to
tell your wife
I'm alive I'm here yeah I will you know
I remember just the one thing I needed
was my my phone and there's videos of me
inside the Ukrainian hospital and they
found me and all I could ask for was my
phone I just want to hold on to my phone
and I finally called her from the train
and uh
because she said that just she says I
was sounding really quite really quite
optimistic I just said I'm okay I'm okay
don't worry I said don't you worry I'm
coming home I'm alive don't worry I'm
coming home I didn't know that Pierre
or Sasha had died at that point
I thought they'd been saved and so that
was a another difficult moment there but
that was the first time I told her and
my wife is the most incredible person
I'm lucky man I married the most amazing
woman and at that moment then she knew
she needed to know everything where to
take me how best to treat me who she had
to speak to and she worked hand in hand
with Fox and the doctors and the
military to find the best place for me
you know she's been stronger than I have
to order this and we've got through it
together
what about seeing your children and the
daughter who appeared to you
in that car out of what you wrote was
deep blackness
yeah well I didn't see my daughters for
about
six months and the decision was that
they wouldn't come and join me in Texas
I decided on my wife that we didn't want
them to see me unable to move so badly
injured you know my three daughters at
the ages if at the time two four and six
and we just thought
it's going to be so unhealthy for them
to come and sit by my bed in ICU and I
can't move
that would be would help me but it
wouldn't have helped them and the
decision was for me to get quick and get
better as fast as I could and then go
home and so again that was about six
months later when I finally got home
again and that moment and I'd been
talking to them on FaceTime and videos
but that moment
I walked in the door and I remember them
just all running and holding on to me
and wouldn't let go just wouldn't let go
tears of joy
everything that I fought for was getting
home every single day no matter how hard
it was that's what I held in my mind
keep going you're going home you'll see
your family again you'll hold your
daughters again well that was for that
moment that moment when I walked into my
house and I still feel that way every
time I hug them every single time I get
this some physical emotion that uh that
I didn't feel before it's amazing
so now as you continue your recovery
what are you thinking about for your
career
well I can't wait to start working again
you know I had a job I absolutely love
more than anything I have met incredible
people and I'm so inspired by their
stories and I want to get back to
telling those stories and for 15 years
I've covered Wars and I've told some of
the worst stories in the world and I've
seen some of the worst things in the
world and um what I've actually realized
now what I would like to focus on are
some of the uplifting things some of the
hopeful stories some of the inspiring
stories the people who came to help me
into Ukraine the doctors who help me all
the people around the staff and our
viewers and our audience who all reached
out those things are so powerful they're
so uplifting that's another thing that
got me through and so I want to go back
to work and I want to start telling that
first some of these uplifting stories I
want to say that these things unite us
there's so much division in the world
the people who are kind and generous and
share themselves and what they've got
that that's the story I want to look at
so I'll go back to the news as soon as I
can when I'm walking a bit better but I
think I want to focus on that as well
and the positives in life
when you look back
I mean did you you were all these areas
I remember we had you on the podcast
after you had gone to like the last Isis
stronghold in Syria and you talked to
one of their captured Fighters I mean
you you were only all these War zones
did you ever think ever imagine that
that that this could happen what did
happen to you
no you know
about seven colleagues of mine have died
over the years you know people I've
known and worked with so I I knew it
happened I knew the the horrors happen
and um but I never never really thought
it would happen to me I always wondered
how I would behave if I was injured or
if I went through it and I'd seen other
people being badly injured before but
you know you have to put your fear aside
to do this job you're going to cover
Wars you have to put aside that fear and
you have to go into it and focus on the
work and the story and that's how you do
it is that you focus on that so I never
never paid too much attention to it
so I didn't think it would happen but it
did happen and to be honest I'm quite
proud with with uh you know but how I've
come through it well it it is inspiring
your optimism your your positive outlook
I would think
with all that you went through
it would be easy
to maybe be bitter or angry certainly
you've seen people who have a hard time
with these kinds of catastrophic
injuries what makes you
be so positive
well I really think the world is an
amazing place it's a kind place it's a
warm place and uh
I don't remember the horrors I don't
remember what's happened to me and think
of my injuries and what happened I
remember the good and I remember all the
people who came there is more good out
there than there is evil I know that and
I think we've all got to go out and live
it and I also think that Pierre Sasha
what a disservice to them if I didn't
make the most of my life if I didn't
grab every opportunity I had I know
they'd want me to do that I'd want them
to do that if it had been the other way
around so I think every day that I wake
up I think today's for Pierre I'm going
to live this repair and Sasha and I'm
going to go and make the best of today
and I'm gonna you know do everything as
as well as I can for them so they give
me strength every single day my family
give me strength every single day and
I've always been kind to me gives me
strength every single day and I have
spoken to a lot of people who have gone
through had similar injuries as I've had
you know veterans and some people don't
come out of it like I have and we've got
to think about them too you know some
people lose their identity and they're
um their confidence and
their future and those are the people
we've got to think about I mean you know
you've got to talk about some of the
suicides that we're seeing among the
veterans so it's it's a real
it's a real problem and you know if I
can do something it's to help reach out
to them perhaps try and show them that
there are good things to work on and not
just big things it's not about trying to
get to the other line it's not doing
small things every day little
improvements every day just find
something else little little to improve
get a little bit further and eventually
those add up and they slowly add up and
then over time
you've come a long way and so you know
I've been very lucky and I hope I can
help others who haven't been so lucky
you referenced it that as a journalist
you tell and have been for years telling
other people's stories has it been
difficult with you being the story the
focus on you
yeah it is funny because you know for
years we've been telling the stories and
I always felt that it's not some
journalists go out there and they tell
the story about how they got there and
what it was like for them and I was
never that kind of a journalist I always
thought that we tell the stories of the
people we meet that's what our audience
need to know they need to know about
them so suddenly here I am and I've
become the story and at first I thought
well maybe that's it's not really what I
want to be doing but I I have started to
see many people being inspired by my
story who are reaching out to me so if
telling my story if becoming the story
can help others then I'm happy to do
that
um I have hope that we can move on and
talk about other you know in the future
talk about other work but for now this
is the focus and I you know I don't mind
it
congratulations your book number one on
the New York Times bestseller list I I
can't imagine you you you thought that
could happen no I was hoping perhaps
that we might make the uh somewhere on
the list and uh I didn't know what
interest there would be in the book
um but I mean it I'm so honored that so
many people have read it so many people
have enjoyed it
um and what I like is that everyone
finds something different in the book
that they like everyone I speak to find
little tidbits throughout that they find
interesting so I I think it actually
works on a whole lot of many levels and
so no I'm I'm really pleased that it's
done well and uh just I suppose thank
you for everyone who's you know who's
who's read the book well I look forward
to a chance to see you in person the
next time uh you can get to New York and
I also look forward to seeing you
back with your reports and the stories
that you'll be doing for us in the
meantime congratulations again on your
new book that is number one on the best
seller list saved a war reporter's
mission to make it home Fox News foreign
correspondent Benjamin Hall a real honor
and a real pleasure and Delight to talk
to you thank you so much no the owner's
mind thank you and I'll see you in
person next time
[Music]
and now some good news with Tanya J
powers
a giant Red Spoon that was stolen from
an Arizona Dairy Queen has been found in
part thanks to a popular outdoor game
app Michael Foster was playing Pokemon
go when he saw the 15-foot spoon on the
ground behind a fence that surrounds a
phoenix Middle School baseball field
that's just a couple miles from the
Dairy Queen where it went missing Foster
says the first thing he did was send a
picture of it to his wife and said it's
the spoon the police were called they
strapped it to the top of a police
cruiser and they've since released video
of the theft which happened on March
25th showing two men and one woman
getting the spoon and putting it on a
large flatbed truck investigators are
still looking for the people who took
the spoon and have asked the public for
tips the owners of the Dairy Queen
that's the home of the spoon say they're
thankful for the discovery it would have
cost them seven thousand dollars to
replace it Tanya J Powers Fox News
[Music]
me Rachel Campos stuffy a former U.S
congressman Sean Duffy as we share our
perspective on the discussions happening
at kitchen tables Across America
download it from the kitchen table the
Duffy spent foxnewspodcast.com or
wherever you download podcasts subscribe
to this podcast at foxnewspodcasts.com
it's time for your Fox News commentary
Robert Jeffress what what's on your mind
occasionally somebody asked me Pastor
what is the hardest thing you've ever
had to do in Ministry I always give the
same answer the experience is seared in
my Consciousness as if it happened
yesterday it was a Palm Sunday at about
three o'clock in the afternoon more than
20 years ago our Church's annual Easter
pageant was going to start in a few
hours I received a phone call telling me
that a couple in the church a husband
and wife had just been killed in a
motorcycle accident the extended family
asked if I would go to the couple's home
to tell their two grade school daughters
that their parents were dead
I thought about that moment again when I
heard about the shooting at the Covenant
School in Nashville several weeks ago
imagine delivering the news to parents
or to Children whose loved ones
innocently went to school and lost their
lives due to a senseless act of violence
what would you say to those experienced
such a sudden horrific loss what Solace
or hope could you offer every worldview
or philosophy should have to answer that
question would you be able to offer
these families any real hope other than
just wishful thinking and sweet
platitudes Easter is the only reason I
have something to say when I look into
the eyes of those who are experiencing
the worst tragedies this life can offer
Easter represents the historical fact
that death has been conquered for all of
human history death had had a perfect
record it was unbeaten from the
strongest and most powerful to the
weakest and most vulnerable death got
them all in the end until Jesus
Christians have insisted from the very
beginning that Jesus died on Good Friday
and was truly resurrected from the dead
on Easter Sunday this wasn't a fable as
the Apostle Peter wrote we did not
follow cleverly devised myths the
Apostle Paul underscored just how
essential the resurrection was to the
Christian faith he wrote If Christ has
not been raised then our preaching is in
vain and your faith is in vain every
alternative explanation put forward by
Skeptics that Jesus appeared to die or
that his disciples stole the body is
far-fetched past the point of absurdity
the Resurrection wasn't trimmed up by
Christ's first followers to make
themselves feel better more than 500
eyewitnesses saw Jesus dead and buried
and then saw him alive again the
resurrection is a fact in the past that
offers hope for our future it means
death is not the end for us or our loved
ones if we believe in Jesus Christ we
will one day receive the very same type
of body he received one that will never
age or get sick again Easter also offers
comfort for the present families who
experience the sting of death of a loved
one experience the darkest moment in
their lives perhaps you have just
experienced a tragedy or lost a loved
one and you're feeling Despair and
heartbreak the message of Easter will
not erase your grief and your pain right
now but through Christ you can
experience grief differently as the
Bible says those who place their faith
in Christ do not grieve as others who
have no hope Easter is God's reminder
that Although our suffering is real it
is also temporary if you are feeling the
sting of death or the pain of any other
loss in your life then I would encourage
you to remember the reality of Easter
the resurrection is a fact in the past
that offers hope for the future and
comfort for the present for all who will
trust in the Jesus who promised I am the
resurrection and the life the one who
believes in me though he were dead yet
shall he live again this is Robert
Jeffress for Fox News
[Music]
you've been listening to the Fox News
rundown and now stay up to date by
subscribing to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com listen ad free on
FOX News podcasts Plus on Apple podcast
and Prime members can listen to the show
ad-free on Amazon music and for up to
the minute news go to foxnews.com
new from the Fox News podcasts Network
I'm Dana Perino join me for season three
of my limited time podcast everything
will be okay based on my best-selling
book of the same name make sure you
subscribe to this series wherever you
download podcasts and leave a rating and
review
love Fox News click the Subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust and click the Fox News rundown
playlist for the latest episodes